Les amis je me suis infiltré dans les locaux d'Ubisoft et j'ai réussi à voler Watch Dogs 2
ou alors c'est Ubisoft qui sponsorise cette vidéo, je sais pas
Oui on parle de Marcus, pas le gars qui présente des émissions sur Game One
J'parle juste de ce gars, le nouveau héro de Watch Dogs 2
Apparemment on peux toujours pirater des choses,sinon ça s'appellerait finalement GTA
On peux par exemple déployer un drône et effrayer les gens avec
Ça marche bien hein
Ah ! J'ai pété mon drone voilà fin du game.
Salut les filles, vous êtes bien dans Watch Dogs 2 ou pas ?
C'est ma première heure de jeu et t'es à ta combientième toi ?
MAIS RÉPONDS MOI !
Oh merde... *rires*  Au moment où il y a la police , mec !
T'es morte, t'es morte ! T'ES MORTE !
Voilà , c'est une mauvaise idée
TIENS !
Oh une moto !
Yolo bitch !
C'est pas grave, c'est pas grave 3 côtes cassés pour une moto gratuite on dit pas non
Oh merde ça arrive ! C'est parti !
Salut les copains !
Raté !
Yolo bitch !
Qu'est-ce que je peux pirater ? Je veux pirater quelque chose !
Venez les gars, venez
Je suis en train de tout pirater mon gars, j'ai jamais autant piraté.
Pfft
Vous avez votre permis ou pas les gars, bordel !
Apparemment Marcus est cascadeur à mi-temps
Franchement ... pas mal du tout
DÉGAGE
ça dégage !
Un sacré homme ce Marcus
même quand il meurt il a du style
OH LA MOTO
MOTO GP JE VEUX
JE VAIS LE PIRATER ARRH
AAARH
Aller hop dégage
Nan la moto se tire toute seule NAN J'AURAI PAS DU LA PIRATER !
elle va ...
AAAAARH Pardons madame :(
:'(
Reviens là putain ...
Arrête tes conneries jeune moto
Laisse moi te CONDUIR-EUH
YOOLOOO
ET LA JE SPAMME ET LA J'SUIS ENTRAIN DE PIRATER TOUTE LA VILLE
J'men bats les couilles !
Enfaite ce qu'on peut faire ...
C'est pirater quelqu'un
Et l'faire passer pour ... je sais pas trop quoi mais un gang ce ramène et le bute
Regardez ça va être terrible
Ah ok on la fait passer pour un traite
Donc le gang ne devrait pas tarder
WHAT THE FUUCK
Ah ça part en couille
je m'tire je m'tire je m'tire
Bon est-ce qu'il ne serait pas le temps de faire une petite mission
Vole le véhicule expérimental du FBI et livre le à Deadsec
Deadsec c'est l'organisation des pirates informatique dans laquelle Marcus est
Aller on y est
Ah c'était beau !
Quel cascadeur ce Marcus !
Ok c'est parti pour la mission !
Il faut qu'on localise le véhicule, il est derrière cette grille
Aucun problème.
Attends j'pense qu'il faut pirater la caméra pour le voir
où est-il ?
Ah déjà ya une porte
D'accord faut que je passe par la
Du coup normalement jvais pouvoir rentrer la
Faut que je pirate ça, pourquoi je peux pas pirater ça
Ah bah nickel !
Alors on va aller en mode discret
YOLO BITCH
J'ai feinté ARRH
Ah lui il sort les armes direct !
Les flics arrivent
oh quel acteur ce Marcus
Bon où est ce véhicule mon gars
il est la !
Et si j'appelle un gang pour niquer les mecs du FBI ?
ça peut être pas mal ça !
Voilà la ya un petit règlement de compte
du coup faudrait que je passe par cette grille la enfaîte
ok c'est ouvert c'est le bon moment c'est le bon moment !
FONCE !
Vas-y faut que j'aille voler le véhicule !
Merde ça c'est refermé putaiiiiin
Oh mon dieu ils se font arrêter les cons du gang la
ils vont bien devoir ouvrir la porte pour sortir on va se cacher la !
c'est le meilleur plan du monde !
effectivement ...
J'suis une grosse merde !
enfaîte les portails sont reliés à un putain de circuit électronique il faut que je trouve ce circuit électronique
Il faut que je pète ce boitier la
comment je peux faire pour le peter ?
AH JE SAIS
On va rappeler des gangs la porte va s'ouvrir
Aller ... non mais ils arrivent de l'autre côté
mais nan mais c'est un sketch
ok pour que les portes puissent s'ouvrir bon la ils sont ouvert parce que j'ai appelé 18 gangs
Attends il m'a ni..
MAIS TU FAIS QUOI TOI AVEC TON CAILLOU ?
NNAAN
Vous m'aurez pas !
J'crois que Parrot va m'adorer tellement je vais devoir leur acheter des drones
hahaha
Alors par où on peut passer ?
Bah par la mec
On va sauter
voilà
On va s'infiltrer :D
YOLO BITCH
ok personne nous a vu
Nan ils m'ont vu ils m'ont vu NAN arrêter ! UNLOCK
on peut y arriver vas-y unlock le !
Oh mon dieu qu'est-ce qu'il fait je sais pas on dirait R2D2
C'est bon ça a marché ?
ça a marché !
du coup là est-ce que je peux ouvrir cette putain de porte ?
c'est vrai tu as raison tu as raison
voilà
OH MON DIEU
NAN NAN NAN laissez moi laissez moi !
ARRRH qui a garé cette voiture comme ça ?
le pire hacker de tous les temps
ok les gars cette fois ... on va pas blaguer
d'accord
Bon j'sais pas qui a mis cette palette la mais c'est un gros fdp
Ah bah voilà une entrer parfaite pour drone putain
ET BIIM
est-ce que la porte s'ouvre ?
où est la voiture ? la voiture est juste la les gars
OUUI
Je dis oui !
Aller à plus je m'barre avec votre véhicule les gars
ça m'a fait grave plaisir
on s'appelle !
je m'barre !
on peut pas couper à droite la ? si on peut couper à droite regardez
HOP raccourci bitch
ET voilààààà
C'est pour vous les gars !
Merci à tous !
Sans aucune difficulté
c'est toi qui t'embrouille au téléphone et qui fait chier tout le monde mais putain j'en croise tout les jours dans le métro des comme ça !
et je leurs fait la même chose qu'à toi !
c'est faux je change juste de rame
RACCOURCI !
Ah la branche elle aime pas les raccourcis
aller yolo on fonce !
ok les gars j'suis la
souvent les mecs en Harley quand ils s'arrêtent ils font ça
Oh moi je veux un bus je veux conduire un bus !
Aller ! OHLALALALA
putain les gars on vient de réaliser un rêve on a ouvert notre compagnie de bus
C'est fantastique !
Voilà bah c'était marrant 10 minutes d'ouvrir sa compagnie de bus
les gars j'vous laisse
Oh putain :')
MAIS QUE VOICI !
Il est torse nu en plus le kéké ça dégage !
Qui peut me stopper je viens de loin !
Et vu mon teint
Je dois faire les choses bien
La Fouine - Qui Peut Me Stopper
petite photo où quoi les gars ? ptit selfie aller
OUUUAIS
Merci les gars ... aller viens en s'en va tout les deux
loin de ta copine ... regarde elle t'a largué !
ALLER TOCARD !
Les amis j'propose de customiser légèrement
sa palette nan sa tenue
ET J'suis garé !
Attends
Et bah regarde c'est ma moto qui ouvre la porte du magasin qu'est ce que tu vas faire ?
Alors !
On va se mettre en mode stylé
Ouais ... 499 dollars le tee-shirt dollar
enfaîte c'est les billets que j'ai donné pour l'acheter qui ont collé dessus à ce prix la
C'est ça
Le petit effet corps de Squeezie c'est très bien
Ok j'suis Captain America
au niveau des chaussures Ah bah voilà c'est très bien ça !
Je peux me permettre
On dirait que tu t'es chier dessus avec un pantalon comme ça
donc j'prefère plutôt
VOILA LE PETIT SHOOORT
mais regardez moi ce style !
mais qui peut le stopper?
HEIN
ça c'est juste pour le prix du tee-shirt ça m'avait énerve
Eh bah voilà les gens c'est déjà la fin de la vidéo sur Watch Dogs 2
j’espère que ça vous à plu si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo comme d'habitude
ça sort le 15 novembre prochain
j'aime bien faire des vidéos sur des gros jeux comme ça parce que mine de rien on en fait jamais
voilà donc ça permet de varier les plaisirs
et c'est cool de faire de tout des jeux 1D, du pas jeu vidéo, du blockbuster
euh voilà
voilà j'avais envie de le dire
qu'est-ce qu'il se passe
tu veux que j'hack ton cellphone ? j'envoi des SMS à ta mère ? tention hein
J'fais parti des DeadSec mon pote !
Aller à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo merci d'avoir regardé portez vous bien !
Tchao les petits amis !
C'est Marcus qui aurait dis ça mais pas celui de Watch dogs celui de Game one
PEACE !